do you guys think body count matters
for men and for women it's a very
different subject isn't it vice versa
for me personally from woman to a man no
but i understand it's very crucial the
other way around yeah very crucial like
we don't care about their body count but
they don't want someone
yeah they don't
more times they have their higher body
count but as well yeah
that's why
a man should have the higher body count
let's be realistic but
it's not guaranteed now
i've been putting in work from nowadays
these women are putting in work from
early
there's young girls talking about some
body count levels that they're like
let's say you're 20. i'm not going to go
into it but there's some 20 year olds
yeah there are some there are some yeah
no but the guys they're on the map the
guys who do you think they didn't no no
that's nice thank you who do you think
they're doing
but it's a it's a again it's a different
kind of team but it's a small percentage
of men so one in three men
under the age of 30 either have not
slept with anyone in a year or more
that's why or are very conditional or
are virgins
so no no so again like we're going back
to it's a very small percentage of men
so when you're saying like oh the men
are wild like that's right you're not
you're not talking about men you're
talking about
the chats like the the the hot guys like
you're talking about five ten percent
i've seen some ugly guys
you see but you have to understand even
even even the guys that you think are
ugly they're getting no no even the guys
that you think are ugly are probably
satisfying like a couple biological
things that women look for so like for
example for example like they're
probably tall they might be ugly or less
attractive but they're probably tall and
the funny thing is the funny thing is
like usually when i see
girls call guys ugly a lot of times they
call guys ugly that i would say facially
have a more symmetrical face than them
yeah i don't i don't even like when
people call people ugly really as a
thing so so like i'll i'll rate people
because i i do this like sort like
because i try to get people on my show
right but you can rate people like one
to ten and the way i do it is like eight
like it's a kevin samuels he had this
scale eight to ten is like model five
six is like pretty cute and so like a
lot of times i'll see girls like call
guys ugly but like i literally think
they're on the same level yeah
[Music]
a lot
a lot that
that's interesting
so like even usually even the guys that
like they call ugly like still satisfy
something because otherwise you know
girls
no girl is going to sleep with the guy
that's broke ugly and that meant that
that meant that mandy called him sure
he could be the good guy the one who
could be the good guy always ugly man
making sexy money
see it there he could be the good guy
making bread he could be the protector
provider he could be the good guy yeah
but the the problem is
like women are we can't undo our biology
and like women aren't attracted to like
we're still attracted to the [ __ ]
trait which isn't necessarily an [ __ ]
to the ability to stand up for yourself
and a lot of guys like are too too nice
they don't have a backbone it's not
really nice it's like they just don't
have a backbone and they don't know how
to stand up for themselves they might be
like
a good quote-unquote good guy but you
don't want a guy that's like not gonna
lead you and not gonna put you in your
place ever 100
that's i always say it comes down to the
dna and the core essence of a man and a
woman you know so i always say whether a
woman is a unemployed or runs a fortune
500 company in a at the essence of
things when it really gets down to it
she's going to want a man to lead
and i don't think that changes in
anything in any standpoint i'm never
going to change my mind on that so when
women are like oh yeah i'm a boss [ __ ]
i do this
i just think you haven't met the right
man to kind of put you to put to put you
in your place basically and kind of like
let that you trust enough to take the
will to be like okay i respect you i
admire you enough you take the will and
lead you know they might fight against
it and they'll be like i don't want that
i don't want this but i think when
they're doing all of that they're
testing so when women are harsher man i
don't complain when i see women are hard
on men and they're like talk to them a
certain way or this that the other i
don't complain about that because i
think that's what they should do
to find out if you are you man enough to
lead my man in lead and look after me so
i don't have any problem if you're rude
if you're this to that like i won't
accept it personally but i understand
why women do it because they have to
test to see because it comes down to
that same thing are you man enough to
kind of i don't i don't think so i don't
think there's anything you agreed with i
don't think there's an excuse for being
an [ __ ] tonight
yeah the women no i don't listen it's up
to you this is my thing is people can do
whatever they want yeah there's no
excuse it's up to you how you deal with
it when they yeah that's my point that
she could say well you could do what you
want you could be the biggest idiot you
could be the dumbest [ __ ] on earth
it's up to me if i'm going to accept it
if you're such a [ __ ] that you're going
to let her talk to you like that then
that's your prerogative she
i'm just saying that as if she's
entitled to do it if she can do it and
get away with it she's it's the man's
fault it's not her fault it's the man's
fault because no one ain't gonna talk to
me like i'm a fool you just get put in
place one time or i won't deal with you
and that's that and we move
and i still think it's i think it's a
girl's fault if you're being a [ __ ] for
no reason no if a girl's being in the
[ __ ] it's a girl being a [ __ ] to the
guy i'm talking about yeah yeah like i
accept it that's right that's his
prerogative don't give me like yeah but
there are some girls i know what you're
talking about there's some girls some
girls that are just [ __ ] for no reason
that's actually a personality
yeah
people are there's people like that for
no reason it's up to you to entertain
role models yeah are you gonna say
where's their dads
daddy issues is a big thing in that
department i think
of knowing what the right guy is and how
to spot them and what to look for
oh my gosh
i agree i
oh my gosh i call my dad actually and i
tell him about the guys i'm dating i
could not do that no
no it's not an american thing
you call your dad and talk about the guy
dayton
no most americans don't do that oh
exactly no no
you think that's a policy i'm way too
close with my family thing that's cool
though no but it's actually helped me to
be honest because i'll be like okay like
this this this and this and i'll tell
him and then he'll like
i listen to what he says i just i'm like
you can pick my husband because i don't
want to
i would want look at the leg
the last time i didn't listen i ended up
in like a very toxic relationship so i
was like i learned my lesson i was like
i'm going to talk to you about how that
sounds your dad your dad's a man that's
probably got a little is he still are
you dad and your mom's still together oh
come on
yeah no it's
it's good but that's why i like i
genuinely think like father should be
more involved in like hundreds
like i think a lot of like every i swear
to god every time i haven't listened to
my dad or my brother is like i've ended
up in a situation because we know they
know they know the mind state of a man
they know the mindset of a man as a man
you know the mind state of other men
more than women and there's certain
things that we want only a dad or a
brother will tell you like when i have
female friends i always say i tell them
a lot of things and i say to them i want
you to know everything i know so you
don't miss the tricks and you don't miss
things but sometimes you don't want to
listen you have to learn the hard way
which we do i mean depends who the role
model is because that's right my dad's
telling me this i'm like why are you
[ __ ] blocking but if my male friend is
telling me this maybe i have to open my
ears if my mother your dad is your dad
is is he like why wouldn't you listen to
him because he's just like
on my case like i think he just doesn't
want me to get married at all because
i'm like his baby girl so he's like you
can't talk to anyone at all you can't
marry you can't marry anyone don't look
in a guy's direction he gets so
protective over me like i understand i
think it comes out of a place of like
you don't think if you had like a good
guy interested in you he would be okay
with it no really
over the test of time like if they were
consistent
he would probably kill him
your dad's not playing at all no you
don't no he's too protective i respect
but that's why i always said i didn't
want to do this because i think that's
how i would be i've always said i don't
want to i don't do this because i think
that's i'd be so protective because i
know how men are i'd be i'd
yeah it'd be like knocking the door and
bad boys you know
bad boys and will smith and ramen's dick
he'd be knocking down the door
of like every guy literally
literally everyone's getting brought
into the um the back room like 50 cent
and dennis thieves i'm having all the
man them
when do you guys think it becomes
because on one hand i do like i do think
women should
like have standards right i'm not i'm
not saying women should have no
standards but at what point is it
delusional
when they can't even attain what they
want in the man so say if they want a
really rich man
does the rich man want you though you
need to think about that yeah because
it's a two-way street so you need to be
able to meet his expectations
so that he can meet yours as well
if you have them expectations don't get
mad when he doesn't want you
if you can't
keep up to what he wants
mm-hmm but yeah that's my perspective at
least i have the same same thing i
always thought about what you were
saying as well that women should bring
something to the table when it comes to
that if they're expecting a lot they
should be giving a lot
but i had a conversation with a male
friend a few weeks ago and he mentioned
to me that actually a lot of guys don't
care
about what girls bring to the table if
they're the providers they don't and
they they couldn't care if she works
doesn't work
doesn't drive they don't care i've
always been on the illusion they do
no but i've only learned recently in my
31 years and i feel like they're the
ones that are out there
but they care they do care about um
they care about your like body yeah they
care about the way you look they just
care about they don't they don't care
about what we care about because we care
about if a guy drives we care if a guy
has a job like a lot of times like girls
will think that guys evaluate them the
way we evaluate that so we'll be like oh
i'm funny he wants a girl that's funny
like
they don't know
they're like is she is she hot is she
available
does she like me back
it's true men go off the physical men do
you go off the physical but for me
i'd say not like you what did you say
your guy friend said you don't care if
you like he doesn't care what girl is
meant
because he's a professional
i'm a provider so i don't care
what they earn or anything like that but
what i do care about is
a work ethic
yeah
that's what i care about work ethic
because if you're just coming and you
just want to be you just want to there
with your hand out that's not attractive
to me but if you've got a work ethic and
i know you're a grinder you want to get
things done you want to work then i want
to look after you i want to put you in a
position where you have to do less or
nothing at all but if you've got some no
work ethic you're just sitting there you
want to just sit look pretty next to me
what's that going to do for me i want to
see once if the work ethic is the thing
that side of you where you want to do
for yourself that's attractive a bit of
ambition you know so that you don't have
to be making loads of money you could be
in a doing whatever but you you've got
aspirations you want to achieve things
or certain things that's attractive not
if you're laying in bed till half two
and then you won't get up for the pin
gold party and no we're not doing all of
that
do you think most guys care about that
depends what you want yeah i'm not going
to lie to you if i just want to smash
then i'm not going to care
you could you could if if your heart my
only instinct is that i want to bend you
over then
you could be flipping
sleep all day part of your nights
whatever i'll catch you in between you
understand but so now most guys don't
care to be for the most part if you're
hot i've had conversations like this on
my podcast if you're demanding don't
care well and the other thing is girls i
think girls think that guys care about
their money so they'll say things like
oh i'm like the one thing girls will say
is like i'm independent yeah but when i
this is this is just a feeling as a girl
and you tell me as a guy if this is true
i think when a girl is like oh i'm
independent i don't need a man a guy
puts her in the friends with benefits
category because like guys want to be
needed and they want to be like wanted
um
when i hear it i don't really take it
seriously because i think like you think
they're capping yeah
because you know what it is like
the king don't need to say he's the king
the lion don't need to say he's a lion
so the fact that you're declaring this
to me is i just think it's just
something you heard it sounds cute
like that so i don't take it that's it i
kind of pinch assault that and keep it
moving no i feel like you can be
independent and not
want like not need a man but you can
still want one yeah yeah yeah i'm
independent i provide for myself but i
don't mind a bit more you know i mean
like no no all day long what i'm
referring to is the one that will tell
you and keep announcing it i'm
independent i don't you see what i'm
trying to say that i'd rather you prove
it yeah just show i'll see it you know
like we'll see i'll see that okay
she's independent she does her thing
that kind of thing rather than that
announcing i don't need a man i do this
i don't need to hear all of that [ __ ] i
thought it was attractive to men too
until recently i thought men wanted
women that said i'm independent and i
soon realized they don't care
if they want to provide they want to
provide right i like strong women i like
successful women i do like strong
successful women because then to me i
that's more attractive to me like when a
strong successful woman
bends to my will or tells me to take the
steering wheel that's more of a thing
than some woman that just needs me
anyway she's like i'll do that but when
you've got your own thing going on and
then you say you know what i respect you
you take the wheel and control it that's
that's that's
when you're doing something but it's
interesting because a lot of
a lot of times if you tell a girl like
that to submit to a guy it's like hell
is freezing over of course i can't
submit to a guy
have you heard that at all
yeah
i have
but it's like
there's some it's probably the girls
that actually are independent that go
mad
the fake ones they'll be like okay calm
all right let's do this well there has
to be a leader and a follower in a
relationship
even even some girls do leads
yeah but something like that yeah but
they but they they don't like their the
guy they're away some actually do i
agree crazy they don't
because if they really like you they're
submitting i'm just being i don't want
to say too much but if they really like
you they're submitting and i've seen it
they'll start with that attitude that
you spoke of they'll start with the no i
don't want it they hate the idea of it
but you know
it's as we said earlier it's in the dna
it's in our course i feel like it's
possible
it's more than whispers like for a woman
to lead a woman to leave
your mom leads
no exactly this is my point in theory it
sounds good i know what it is in reality
then my your mom might lead you in a way
where you think it's like your dad's
like just kind of bothered and he's
letting her lead but really and truly
for the most part i think men will lead
no but even now when my dad leads i just
look at him
that's because i don't know i look like
that's because your generation you're
the new generation so now the times are
changing so you're looking at things
different but like we said before it's
uh it's been going on for a long time
it's a good thing times are changing
though because yeah he said the man and
we're leading a bit too like i don't
mind the man leader
unless he has sense
if he's senseless then it's pointless
for him to leave obviously she shouldn't
be with him
pick a guy with sense that can lead you
but what if the girl wants to lead
okay if a girl wants to leave she can do
that but she's not going to like the guy
thank you because
women create like we're attracted to the
trait leadership like if a woman okay
okay i'll give you an example if a guy
is a ceo and he's powerful that is hot
to us that's sexy a president that's
sexy okay ceo of
men and that if a man
has a woman's ceo
it's cool
but it's like it's like a shoe
collection to us
so if a dude is a shoe collection that's
cool but i don't we don't care
it's it's whatever and that's what it is
to them so
the
what we're attracted to isn't a guy
that's that's like
that doesn't have the leadership
qualities
and so it's um
yeah i mean they can do it and some
girls do but they always they always
hate their husbands
you put that so wrong it was so poignant
so true i couldn't i couldn't have said
it better myself no but then a lot of